[Music]
it was elon musk versus a dried up old
husk
yes the billionaire takes time off from
space to get in bernie sanders face
it was a ceo who sends rockets through
the air versus a senator who's older
than dirk
tesla ceo elon musk took to twitter over
the weekend responding to senator bernie
sanders demand that rich people pay more
in taxes and by rich bernie means people
who own more than three houses
gentle rumble of laughter bernie tweeted
quote we must demand that the extremely
wealthy pay their fair share period
it only took him three hours to write
that tweet with those mittens on
to which the world's richest man
responded quote i keep forgetting that
you're still alive
uh elon gets a bigger laugh than i do
want to sell more stock bernie just say
the word so elon recently sold roughly 7
billion dollars worth of tesla stock
after conducting a twitter poll asking
his followers if he should which is
exactly how you should make investment
decisions by twitter poll only if you're
a billionaire but a goddess wondering
what must bernie sanders think about
this
this is not anything radical because we
had these laws you wake up late for
school man you don't want to go you ask
your mom please but she still says no
had usury laws until 1978 when they were
repealed you missed two classes and no
homework but your teacher preaches class
like you're some kind of jerk banks to
charge
extortion level you gotta fight for your
right to party
speaking of party i shouldn't have had
those buffalo wings last night should
not be
uh using people's misfortune oh
god now i'm feeling the burn as a basis
for extortion i gotta get out of here
tyrus it's kind of sad that of the two
men that are feuding one of them almost
became president and it's not the
billionaire
no it's the multi-millionaire or
100 million you know
we need to tax the rich that has
nothing to do with its socialist but
he's not he's in a unicorn anyways
because he's a rich socialist which kind
of means he's fighting himself but
whatever uh and he's going after elon
musk because he's convinced that's what
the people want to hear
because even if you tax elon musk that's
not going to make our christmas any
better right you know that's not going
to fix our schools it's not going to fix
what's going on in our streets but yeah
let's go after him and then he comes
back with
i you know in his defense if he had just
one billion maybe he wouldn't be so
cocky yeah but when you have 265 billion
what's 65 billion among friends and what
i'm saying like i mean well bernie
didn't even go after him he said we just
need to tax the rich and he's like hey
that's me speaking
he's talking about me i'm rich and he's
like he's you know the richest man in
the world and he still feels the need to
go on twitter and call some vermont
center be like you're old like i love
that yeah yeah i love it i love the fact
that elon musk behaves like this
occasionally not all the time like
really he's just one of the very few
very famous people who clearly does have
control of his own twitter account yeah
exactly he sends these things out
sometimes you think oh that's you yeah
no one else would do that and but he has
you know fu money yeah yeah he has
nothing to worry about no one's gonna
cancel him
although kat
i still don't respect him after what he
did to grimes i knew that you were gonna
go there
i'm sorry but you did call it yeah you
thought that they would have a kid and
then they'd break up yes he said yes i
knew that way i invested in it i knew
that would happen this is what happens
in the meetings i never show up
okay i don't think that's more
the one thing that katie that drives me
a little crazy is that
we have given up any kind of opportunity
to counter somebody who talks about fair
share like if somebody says you need to
pay your fair share they can say that no
matter what the percentage you pay so if
one percent
of the of of the american population is
paying 40 of the taxes that's still not
enough because it's never enough it's
never enough uh bernie sanders owns
three more homes than elon musk he sold
all of his homes that's right he's three
more than he does
this is a weird thing that the left does
they say they want to achieve a goal so
for example the green new deal which
bernie sanders supports which means we
need a lot of electric vehicles well
elon musk happens to know how to produce
electric vehicles and yet they're
constantly trying to destroy him so at
the same time they're demanding the
private sector get on board with this
big government program they're trying to
make sure he has less money to build the
electric cars that he needs so that
doesn't make sense but i do love that
he's like you know what man forgot that
you kind of exist yeah and uh
you know threatens to sell more stock to
make it harder for bernie sanders to do
that why is it that aoc whenever she
talks talks as if she's speaking to a
child who's never heard english
it's just every single thing
now
yes let me tell you but see that it's
coming from you see you're like whenever
you talk it's like bathing in warm milk
yeah i don't know why you put me on with
a guy with a nice accent that was really
rude
that's the best i didn't even notice
that yeah no but you know british you
know he's just british but i answer your
question she's speaking to herself which
is why she's speaking
when she was taught that's how the video
told her to speak if you if you watch
aoc and when she's in public it it's not
really a rally it's like six people she
learned that if you jump and point yes
while you talk you can keep listening
that's what kamala does that too because
it's the same classes
whatever i want to skid my point across
if you point at them and raise your
hands they won't listen to the dumb
coming out your mouth
so just start pop-locking and talk about
stealing everybody's money
there you go